Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Matthew Tai, known online as Lao Wai
86, or Si Milk, who's an American blogger
well known for living in China.
Matthew, so great having you on.
I really appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much.
It's an honor.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, I guess first, just
to kind of orient our audience, how did you
end up living in China for the period that
you did?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I'll give you the CliffsNotes
version.
But basically, I was bored out of college.
I didn't really want to settle down and get
a job immediately.
I had just backpacked through Europe.
I was like, Why not go travel somewhere else?
China wasn't even on my list.
I was like, Why not do some sort of gap year?
Maybe teach, you know, teach English abroad
for a year and then come back home and then
get a job.
So I initially thought, you know, Taiwan sounds
pretty cool.
Interested in maybe learning Mandarin Chinese
might be useful in the future.
So I put up my resume on some Taiwanese job
sites and it just wasn't hiring seasoned at
the time.
But I guess some mainland Chinese companies
also poach like potential employees on those
sites as well.
Because I got a phone call from this like
tiny, tiny little school in Guangdong in Hawaii,
who actually the picture behind me is the
city behind me called me up and said, hey,
do you want to do a year here instead?
And I you know, I didn't really consider I
was like, you know, China is a pretty it seems
like a pretty crazy place.
But at the same time, why not go on another
adventure and try it out and, you know, sold
all my stuff.
I was just a young, you know, 22 year old
kid and hopped on a plane and went over there.
Speaker 1: And I have a number of viewers
who have called me sometimes when we'll open
up our phone lines and they say that they
are in China teaching English.
What other things do Americans sometimes do
in China when they're there?
Speaker 4: Sure.
Yeah.
So I didn't continue teaching English the
entire time.
It's kind of just your it's a way you get
you when you get off the plane.
It's what you do.
Right.
But a lot of people, you know, they'll oversee
factories, they'll do consultation for like,
what's it called, like quality control.
They'll do help with immigration visas and
stuff for people that want to move abroad.
There's people that'll start their own bars.
You know, it's like a it's not an open market,
but it's a huge market.
So a lot of people, especially during China's
golden period, which I call like kind of like
when I was there 28 up until I mean, I left
around 2018, but up until like 2014 was like
a golden period for people to go there and
try out a new market, go try a new product,
try to get Chinese people interested in something
that they can find at home that is not already
popular in China.
Speaker 1: So there's how do you even broach
this next part?
I mean, there's no shortage of reporting about
an authoritarian status quo in China to different
degrees and affecting different people.
We have the weaker population specifically
and we've done interviews about that.
Then there's people like you who are Americans
who may be there on a temporary basis, and
your circumstances presumably would be different
than someone who is from China and living
in China just to get us into this.
Can you give us a general overview of what's
accurate about the reporting that we hear
about the Chinese government and what maybe
is is less accurate, generally speaking?
Speaker 4: Sure.
So when I was initially there, I mean, I didn't
set out to cover any news or influence anything
about China other than the fact that I wanted
to put out videos to show people that it's
not the boogeyman.
Like, people are like, what are you doing
over there?
Why did you move to such a crazy communist,
authoritarian country?
And I just wanted to put videos out there
to be like, listen, it's not it's not as bad
as what you think.
Or maybe the things that you're thinking of
are not actually true, at least in my life,
from my perspective or my Chinese friends.
Right?
So that's what I initially did.
And I actually moved into as my channel and
got bigger and stuff.
And I, you know, my business partner, people
might know him out there.
Winston, he is the first China blogger, the
first guy to actually get on a VPN and put
out videos from China.
I happened to be the second we met each other
and we started doing TV shows.
We started doing travel documentaries.
And again, our goal was we set up a small
motorcycle business where we built our own
custom motorcycle.
So we rode through the country and we rode
we didn't go through the places like that.
You know, people normally see Shanghai, Beijing.
We went through the rural countryside.
We went through the small towns, the third
tier cities, all these places that don't get
reporting.
So we wanted to show a human face of China,
and we didn't set out to do that from the
lens of like, Oh, this is so unfair the way
it's portrayed.
We just wanted to show reality, right?
So from that perspective, we developed our
own insight onto what was actually happening
in the country.
And as we traveled more and the more people
and relationships we developed, the more we
realized that.
Unfortunately, a lot of stuff that people
talk about in regards to China are more of
a macro scale.
But China has a lot of issues and a lot of
them, I'm going to say the majority of them
do stem from the Chinese government.
And when we would go to some of these villages
and find out that maybe an official, for example,
a local official went unpunished after raping
a 14 year old girl and then having her murdered,
we would be shocked to hear this.
And it's weird because the people in this
village, they normally probably wouldn't talk
about that to anyone else.
But because we were foreigners that showed
up, there were some sort of like trust or
understanding that that we would understand
would be would kind of get their perspective
and we wouldn't stick around long enough to
face any repercussion.
And the more people like that we met, the
more beholden we felt to tell the story of
actually what's happening.
When we were in some of these far flung areas,
we would find out that the People's Liberation
Army of China would go and harass families
and harass tribes like Mongolian tribes and
things like this for money to just keep them
down.
Their languages were being banned out of schools.
The people would tell the stories about how
they felt trapped because they're an ethnic
minority.
And China doesn't allow them mobility or it
doesn't allow them to do really anything,
especially upwards mobility, owning their
own business, making money.
And we found out that there's actually a lot
more than what Western media is portraying.
I think the Western media portrays a lot of,
you know, financial based things, or we'll
focus on one specific issue, which is great.
I mean, like I absolutely focus on the weaker
issue.
It's a huge thing.
I personally know weaker people that have
gone through this.
I'm in personal contact with people that have
lost their families to the genocide in western
China, but also like the stories of the inner
Mongolian people, the stories of the ethnic
minorities in the South.
I became very dedicated to kind of compiling
these stories in my head while I was there,
knowing I couldn't report from China at the
time and then saving them for when I ultimately
had to leave China.
Speaker 1: So let's dig into a couple of things
you said.
You said in some of the, you know, third tier
cities, you wouldn't stick around long enough
that there would be repercussions.
And then you just said some of the stories
you knew you couldn't report on while you
were there.
Why?
Why not?
Why did you have to leave the cities?
What would the repercussions be?
What would happen if you tried to report on
them?
Speaker 4: So what happened was when we we
would have the nicest of intentions.
Let's say we show up at a, you know, a third,
fourth, fifth tier city somewhere down in
Guangdong Province.
Let's just pick a random province in the south.
And what would happen is we would you know,
of course, you show up, you're a foreigner
from the middle of nowhere, like you're in
the middle of nowhere.
And people crowd around you.
They want to talk to you.
They want to take pictures, the all that kind
of stuff, that's normal.
But when you sit down with people and you
start sharing a meal, when you start talking
about things and they, you know, you're not
inciting these conversations.
They're they're bringing these things up and
they start talking about what life is like
there, how they haven't received any of the
poverty alleviation type funds, how their
their town is going to be flooded by a dam
that the government's putting in, even though
that nobody wants it there.
Those conversations perked the wrong ears.
So like people will be in the background,
people will be around there that have to report
to local Communist Party officials.
And what will happen is they'll find out,
you know, through the grapevine quite quickly
that there's foreigners there and that they're
not supposed to be there because there are
entire areas in China where foreigners are
not even supposed to be.
And you don't hear about this.
This is again, you wouldn't see this on reporting.
You wouldn't read about this anywhere.
But there are whole areas that are basically
blacklisted off because the Chinese government
doesn't want another Xinjiang story to break.
They don't want another Tibet story to break.
They don't want people talking about issues
that are caused by the government leaking
out to potential journalists, even though
we weren't.
And so you would have a situation where you'd
be in an area and then you'd kind of get this
inkling, this feeling that, number one, the
hotels won't even let you stay.
Stay there.
They're like, no, we can't register a foreigner.
You know, whether they got tipped off by someone
or not is a different story, but they just
won't even register you.
So you could stay there so you're forced to
leave anyway.
But when you get the feeling that people are
starting to like make phone calls and then
you start to see police officers and things
like this, you know, it's time to leave.
Because the times that we did stick around,
we've been told by police officers that you
actually have to get on your bike and just
get the hell out of there.
And what we noticed sometimes is when we would
be in these areas later on, we would see actual
police officers sometimes in notepads or their
phones at certain kind of designated points
on the road from the next from where we just
left to the next city.
So we'd be monitored the entire time.
And you realize that, you know, especially
when you travel around rural China, you realize
that it's very much akin to the security apparatus
that maybe like a place like North Korea would
have.
It's just not is in your face.
It has more money.
Right.
So you're minded the entire time.
And ultimately we found out.
Really how bad it can get.
When we were up in Inner Mongolia and our
hotel room was just full of SWAT team people
with body cameras and automatic weapons.
That's when you realize that I'm here trying
to film some horses and talk to some local
people about their way of life.
And then there's a SWAT team and detectives
in my hotel room interrogating me about my
every movement in the entire country.
Speaker 1: Now, when something like that happened,
after they're done interrogating you, do they
leave and then you just kind of finish what
you were doing?
Speaker 4: No, that's that that's the worst
part, is that there's a system of I don't
know, I think they want to instill some sort
of paranoia, because what they'll do is I'll
use the example in the hotel room of the SWAT
team.
What they'll do is be like, okay, we didn't
really get what we wanted.
You know, they they list off where we work,
what our contracts were, where we shop 2000
miles away, by the way.
And they know everything about you and they
want to get in your head because later on
they'll continue to harass you.
So you think everything's fine, you'll leave
super early the next morning to go on to your
next destination, and then you get stopped
by the army like that, that later that day,
early in the morning, we had stopped by the
PLA, the People's Liberation Army, who made
us take apart all of our equipment, check
everything, take photos, told us not to smile
in the photo, stand in front of everything,
and they would leave.
And then immediately they would come back
and do the exact same thing over and over
again until you just get out of their jurisdiction.
Right.
At the same time, after your trip is over,
the police still come to your house.
They come to visit where you are.
They come to interrogate you.
Why?
Why do you own a drone?
Why are you doing this right?
And it's this constant kind of harassment.
And it's it's kind of the the moment you realize
that, hey, I'm not welcome here with a camera.
They don't want people they don't want foreigners
walking around with cameras, talking to people.
And so that kind of false security you built
up over ten years.
You know, you watch that shift with the current
regime.
By the way, this this really came to fruition
maybe around 2015, and it started getting
really bad.
But you watch this happen and it breaks your
heart and it also makes you feel like what
if if the Chinese government is trying to
hide this stuff so badly, there is so there's
so much under the surface that people don't
actually know about.
And that's what I feel beholden.
You know, I feel beholden to the people to
talk about today because I, I get thousands,
thousands of Chinese people reaching out,
telling me, please keep your voice up.
Please keep talking about this kind of stuff
because we can't talk about that stuff.
Speaker 1: Right.
The the social credit system, I've read quite
a bit about it specifically in the context
of the wiggers, and we interviewed Jeffrey
Kane about his book and he writes specifically
about how how it's sometimes used to restrict
the movement of the weaker people and in other
ways.
Can you talk a little more generally just
about how for the average person living in
China and maybe there is no such thing, maybe
it's very different urban versus rural or
whatever the case may be.
How does that system affect the average person?
Speaker 4: Yeah, so the social credit system
is I've done a huge basically a documentary
series on the whole thing.
What it is, is it's more of a dynamic thing
that's being tested out.
So I think a lot of people I wanted to go
out there and dispel this myth that it's some
sort of number that hangs over your head like
a black mirror or something.
It's not it's not that at all.
In fact, that it was it was rolled out in
this place called Rong Chung in Shandong,
in northern China.
And it was the first place that they they
rolled it out.
And it's no secret.
In fact, I found the government documents
that are out there in public, and I translated
them myself.
And that's what I based my video on.
And what it did was teach me how it works,
you know, from a test standpoint, testing
out on the city and its people.
It's mandatory there, but it's not necessarily
something that's used elsewhere.
Right.
There are other cities.
In fact, I reached out to a lot of people
around China to ask them if they even knew
about it.
I would say a good chunk of people hadn't
even heard about it.
But then there were there were cities, there
were other cities.
And like in Chengdu and I talked to people
in NY, I talked to people all over China that
did know about it.
In fact, their city had some sort of version
of it.
And what it is, it's really trying to reward
good behavior with a point based system and
then punish bad behavior.
And unfortunately, when I went through those
documents and I spoke to people around China,
it looks like it's trying to reward good societal
behavior, which is probably a fine it's a
fine thing.
It's like, you know, I don't have a criminal
record, so my score goes higher.
Right.
But unfortunately, a good proportion of those
crimes, of those things that lower your score
are things about speaking out against the
government, about posting messages of dissent
on on forums or on on chat groups, on, you
know, having weird religious beliefs, as they
call it, you know, cult like religious beliefs.
It turns out that a lot of it is aimed at
reducing personal freedom so that people don't
dissent against the government.
Speaker 1: Once you're sort of branded or
stigmatized or assigned, you know, a lesser
status, whether it's specifically point based
or not, how do you recover from that?
How can you how can you get back to sort of
being on everyone's good side, so to speak?
Speaker 4: Well, unfortunately, if you're
on like the low that this is what I pointed
out in my in my video series is that when
I spoke to people, there's no even though
there's a sliding scale of points, if the
government deems you the lowest score, you
just get the lowest score.
There's not there's no rule of law, rhyme
or reason in this.
I think people really rely on this western
lens of like everything works to a certain
standard.
Everything works because of rules and laws
is not really how it works.
Like if China wants to throw you the lowest
score and make you like ostracized in society,
they'll just do that right off the bat.
Right.
Especially if it's something about the government
or the story in jail.
But if a person is, like labeled at the bottom,
I mean, your your kids probably aren't going
to get into schools.
Right?
You know, you're not going to be able to get
employment opportunities at least above the
lowest, you know, blue collar kind of construction,
construction type jobs, even if you're well-educated.
And to get out of that, if you're at the bottom,
you're not going anywhere.
But if you get out of that, you have to do
good deeds, right?
You have to participate in local government
activities.
You have to.
I mean, there are there are some clauses in
these documents that say if you rat someone
out, basically that's doing bad things, then
you get to move up.
It's basically a really restrictive way of
keeping people in their spot.
They don't really want people to go up or
down necessarily.
It's almost like there is no recourse for
people to exit once they've already been deemed
at that lower caste.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask about
in the couple of minutes we have left.
You weren't there during the COVID lockdowns,
but.
It's been widely reported that, you know,
there are these videos of the vehicles pumping
out disinfectant on the street, which is,
of course, of questionable or no actual preventive
value for for COVID whatsoever.
The COVID zero strategy of sort of close to
complete lockdown, etc., etc..
Can you talk a little bit about whether any
of what you read about in the context of COVID
was surprising based on your experiences when
you did live live there?
Speaker 4: I know, honestly, like when I see
when I saw the heavy handed approach of, you
know, Xi Jinping's government, really not
just when he took over, but like later on
when he achieved full, full power within this
within the Chinese government, when he consolidated
that power through the anti-corruption drive
and things like this, I wasn't surprised to
see what kind of methodology was coming out
with the Zero-Covid policy, because there's
a there's a thing within the Chinese government,
especially, especially true under the current
leadership, is that they can't be wrong.
So when the Chinese government set out to
say, hey, look at the world failing with the
COVID response, look at we're going to be
the ones that kind of deal with it very harshly
in the beginning.
But we're going to show the world as kind
of as a brand how this authoritarian style
government actually works.
Right.
We can take away people's personal freedoms
and stuff.
But isn't that better than dying?
Isn't that better than millions of people
dying?
And honestly, it kind of worked in the beginning.
I think a lot of people are like, you know,
China's pretty brutal.
But at the same time, you know, look at how
they've dealt with this.
A lot of people didn't die in comparison to
the rest of the world.
Speaker 1: That's, I guess, if you believe
the numbers.
Right.
I mean, there's also a question as to.
Yeah, but of course.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I'm I'm always speaking like
a normal reader.
Yes.
Looking at the news.
Right.
Let's pretend like you believe the numbers.
So then people are in a position to say, you
know what, this other style of governance,
maybe they're not going to jump on and be
like, yeah, China's the future, China's the
way.
But they'll look at it and say, You know what?
Maybe this kind of reporting that I see about
China is not really accurate.
Right.
And what happens is, unfortunately, when you
get new variants, when you get something that
spreads so crazy like al-Muqrin and then the
rest of the world has found out ways to deal
with it, whether it be RNA vaccinations, things
that have been proven to work.
China didn't adopt those things out of faith
to save face, to say that we have our own
homegrown method, we have our own vaccine,
which is not very effective, by the way.
Right.
We have our own lockdown strategies and we've
already put in the work.
So we don't really have to suffer through
this anymore while you guys still have to.
And the rest of the world is kind of saying,
well, what do you mean?
Like it's not number one is not is the new
variants not as bad?
Number two, a lot of our population is vaccinated.
And number three, we have an actual dynamic
approach on how to deal with it that doesn't
necessarily restrict people's personal freedoms.
And China says, nope, nope, blinders on.
We have zero COVID, we have zero COVID, we
have zero COVID.
And that can't be proven wrong because in
the top down leadership in China, there is
no there is no saying that the government
is wrong about their strategy.
They have to be right and see it through.
And we're seeing where Xi Jinping is currently
trying to get into his third term.
He has to make sure that his policies not
only worked, but nobody has any sort of dissent
or disapproval with them.
So we're looking at a situation now where
zero COVID is either going to change and rebrand
to the to save leader leadership face or is
going to continue down this very draconian
route.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with Matthew
Tai, known online as Lao Y 86 or Si Milk.
Matthew, so great speaking to you and really
appreciate your insights.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much, David